What's an event?
It's a difficult question.
Not because we lack definitions,
but because there are too many
definitions.
In my book,
I focus on event in the sense of
something extraordinary takes place.
But with all this,
uh,
a wide span of what we call an event,
I think an elementary structure can be
described in formal terms within a
certain field of phenomena where things
go on the normal flow of things from
time to time something happens,
which as it were retroactively changes
the rules of what is possible in the
sense that something happens,
it is generated by that situation.
Of course,
it's causally produced by that situation
back in a way,
it changes retroactively the whole
situation.
It's a miracle in the sense of the event
would have been an aspect which is
stronger than its own causes.
For example.
Now come a couple of examples that I
hope we will all like in literature.
Why is Kafka Franz Kafka the one that we
all know and love and event?
Of course she has predecessors.
We can say that Kafka implicitly or
explicitly relied on a whole series of
other artists like Edgar Allen Poe,
the story of Ski Visium,
Blake and so on.
But it's not a simple as that because
when you try to isolate in those earlier
authors what makes them predecessors of
Kafka,
you can see that that dimension Kafka
before Cafca is perceptive and only one
staff that is already here as a bar has
the Argentinian writer as he put it in a
wonderful,
concise way.
Truly,
Eh,
all authors,
writers have predecessors,
a truly great writer in a way creates
his own past his own predecessors so
that uh,
yes there are people who influenced him,
but you can see this influence only once
he is here.
And now let me jump to a totally
different domains.
Love,
love in the good old fashion sense,
which is today more and more rare love
as an encounter.
This is why in English and also in some
other language is not all like French.
You use the term fall,
we fall in love.
This is the eventful dimension in what
sense?
Let's say you live a happy life.
You are lucky.
You have a job,
you meet regularly with French,
you are not in love,
but you just make one night's 10th maybe
here and there.
You meet every evening with friends you
drink,
you go to blah,
blah.
Then all of a sudden in a totally
contingent way,
let's say you stumbled on the streets,
somebody helps you to stand up.
It's a young girl or a boy,
blah blah.
And of course it's the love of your
life.
It totally contingent encounter,
but the result can be
that your whole life changes.
Nothing is the same as they say.
You even spontaneously perceive your
entire past life is leading towards this
unique moment.
You know,
the illusion of love is,
oh my God,
I was waiting all my life for you.
This something like this would have been
the love event.
And I think it's getting more and more
rare today.
Many intelligent cultural critics.
Notice how we are almost returning to
pre romantic premodern times when
marriage or love connections were a
matter of uh,
uh,
relatives,
counselors and so on.
Your uncle,
your own day selected whom you will
marry and so on.
Today,
it's similar only instead of all those
old twice uncles and so on,
it's dating agencies,
marriage agencies,
and shown and so on.
What we bought,
they offer us is precisely love without
the fall,
without falling in love,
without this totally unpredictable
promatic encounter.
And that's what I find very sad.
I think that today we are simply more
and more afraid of this eventful.
It counters you encounter something
which is totally contingent,
but the result of it,
if you accept it as an event,
is that your entire life changes.
It's a different story.
Uh,
this is why I think that this avoiding
falling in love is the same phenomenon
as a standard joke that I use in my all
my,
uh,
almost all my books.
You know how we want to date the thing
without the bad aspect of it,
without the price,
we have to pay for it.
We won't,
I don't know.
Uh,
we want,
uh,
sugar without calories.
So we have sweeteners.
We want to be or without alcohol,
we want and so on and so on.
And I claim it's the same thing in
sexuality.
We want brief,
safe sex,
sexual without the fall,
without this fake to attachment.
And I think this is the most set theme
here,
the Tivan what is slowly emerging as
maybe deeper dominant ideology.
Today,
what I ironically referred to us,
western Buddhism life is just a playoff
appearances.
Don't take it too seriously.
Maintain appropriate.
These styles don't get too attached to
where Lee objects.
It's fits perfectly,
this superficial consumerist attitude.
So again,
events are rare.
An event is the traumatic encounters,
which to put it in more learn
philosophical terms retroactively
creates its own costs.